la monsoon non ridicola
dammi un bacio far vedere che c'è un
amore tra di noi danno un bacio dai
tanti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo non
ho vinto io sono familiari
oggi siamo andati su ogni gol abbiamo
organizzato un unico perché visto che
siamo tutti quanti confinati in casa è
giusto ragazzi provare a vedere se
riusciamo a passare del tempo insieme
quindi ragazzi partiamo con i video dio
miglior o madonna
hai un po di tatuaggi ne ti dimetti nome
spettacolare non è uno che per un posto
da far vedere aspetto che devo mettermi
in piedi sua scrivania aspetta è un po
un casino però mannaia guarda ha visto
maglia non sapete tutto ecco dico bene
tutto a posto tutto a posto non è caduto
cliente figurati che desta fa la foto
sia come sono video sto facendo anch'io
sono pari ciao bella di mando un bacio
ma che ieri di euro no ma chi fa merito
pure a me che è successo perché
praticamente l'incontro dura con la
pasta al pesto che sarà butta addosso ha
incontrato una con la pasta al pesto si
maestà di più questo è giallo zafferano
questo e un eagle senti in periodi di
quarantena ognuno si diverte
io la doccia ma faccio con l'acqua poi
non so tempo la modifica non piace il
colore azzurro è sì sei sicuro sì
secondo me ti piace con l'azzurro non so
perché c'è questa però ama chi sei un
tipo da azzurro sì mi fa molto piacere
conoscerti spiega milana che fai sti
giorni che stai a casa
niente guardò netflix bravo mi piace
però devi guardare un altra roba molto
importante tu lo sai cos'è di tre no
quello è anche quello però prima fa vj
coi libri si dice così no vabbè sempre
dai primari lanzi prima i libri di fa vj
giusto così ok apposti your boots ciò
dei camini veramente orribile aspetta
aspetta
no è un video registrato questo le
diverse stai scherzando
sto scherzando detto così aspetta fammi
indovinare di dove sei
il co di una frase di una frase normale
tipo guardo i tuoi video da mai non so
neanche chi minchia 6 villa nel mio
dialetto non ho tu proprio guarda i tuoi
video da cinque anni
la pole è bravo rafa era facile dove
tutto a posto e che fa il dio è posto a
posto cosa che fai
in da house niente telefono ogni tanto
ad un libro quello giunto con chi ogni
tanto ci provava anche a scuola poi
basta ho smesso anche questo
anche questo io lo apro e lo chiudo
senza motivo bene così
e ancora non è successo niente strano ma
teoricamente dovrebbe comparire mi una
patente se faziosi in realtà era
materializzata solo mezza ti faccio
vedere la fine di far così l'ho presa
solo per metà la guarda ma tenta e mezza
e se continua ad aprire chiudere si
materializza tutta quindi continuerò a
farlo per un po di tempo ma che salverà
della mia mamma ho paura di questa cosa
va bene ma salute lorenzo il signor post
signor a casa un bacio stato in casa
apple e cose bene tutti in bacio madame
tutto a posto
sei stai facendo tu no no no no la
nostra tv un muro quello dietro che a
noi la catechesi la tua a note di donna
sapeva il resto della stanza sembrava un
televisore gigante come tutto a posto
io sto sudando freddo sta sudando freddo
ecco brava questo è il primo sintomo
nostro scherzo con questa è cosa stai
facendo in casa isti dei completamente
niente io faccio nicolò a questo punto
ecco spammer momento sto disegnando un
po ma se non più disegni fammi vedere
una roba così un attimo e io so quanto
un po presto bello quello sono mi chiedo
la mattina che fu allora questo è ha un
non so che di van gogh
incrociano non ha tremato quando non mi
intendo una sega di arte prof a niente
ma che figo e tagliente materico si vede
prescinde da voler o farlo veramente
figo molto brava molto grati talento
come ti chiami asia asia piacere
giovanni mi piace un sacco di disegni
bravissima kit goran ci vediamo in giro
allora mi faccio mai a te ti conosco
tesoro ma tu sei con ghost aspetta sei
le prove 2.6 quello che fa i balli di
come cazzo di michael jackson quello
l'autobus non ti ho visto in due robe ti
ho visto anche in un video una volta mi
pare quale già pd python visto c'eri tu
praticamente facevi la nostra strana di
se l'è vista delle serie skype
bravo quel giorno mi chiamo vi sia bravo
luca piacere mi chiamo lorenzo sono un
grande estimatore aspetta lorenzo è
detto io mi chiamo lorenzo si tu dove
non dirmi niente che tu mi vieni a
conoscere si è letta allora tu se non
sbaglio mangiare la nutella d'epoca
bravo ero io quello che ti aspetta
spenti di pugliese deciso dai di fausto
leali vicino sono alla fame
le fave però quasi quasi un po più arabo
fa vj bravo premi lui c'era il tizio
roma dove hai fatto anche era la parodia
di docente di scherma de corato bra una
volta no no no no sentiva posso farti
una foto certo che qui perfino aspetta
un secondo spa esattamente i ragazzi
questo era omegle è il primo del 2020
cosa vuoi tu qua calcava il primo mickle
del 2020 spero di farne un altro molto
figo
volevo dirvi che noi creators noi
creators che non si dice più youtuber è
vecchio come termini abbiamo creato
l'ashtag io mi diverto a casa che è una
cosa molto carina da fare perché se ci
pensate a casa
ci sono un sacco di cose che si possono
fare per divertirsi ti può fare i video
col cane
quindi ragazzi utilizzate lascia che io
mi diverto a casa che è molto più carino
dell'astag normale io resto a causa in
realtà fatemi sapere se volete un altro
mi golpe per concludere come sempre
ragazzi se il video è piaciuto lasciate
con un commento è un mi piace molto
iscrivetevi al canale mannaggia a voi e
noi come sempre ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]